i think the story i do want to cover is
tom brady's diet because it could be
shocking for some people here
so tom brady his schedule came up which
is not a crazy skill the schedule's not
going to shock anybody
but i think the diet is very very
interesting so the guy is a 5 30 morning
wake-up call
drinks electrolyte water then smoothie
then 7 a.m breakfast with his family
8 to 10 30 hits the gym strengthening
conditioning beach time 11 o'clock
review game footage noon lunch 3-5 team
practice or in the off season surf and
workout the guy surfs and works at five
to six post workout
playability session 6 pm dinner with
family 7 p.m review films
strategy with coach charity work 7 30
family time including reading with kids
8 30 lights out and sleep 8 30 lights
out wow
sleep okay he doesn't even get to watch
sunday night football or the morning
yeah i mean that's apparently that's
apparently what he's playing now
now here's his workout routine okay
he's micromanaged the athlete's training
uh
for months and even years in advance an
average day will begin
early with pre-workout deep force
massage session with guerrero
it only lasts four minutes but targets
20 muscles groups for 20 seconds each
and it helps prepare brady's body for an
intense workout beginning with 40
minutes of resistant band
to make muscles more pliable soft and
resilient
as a quarterback has age he works out
less with weights which could
leave pro him prone to muscle tears
which
it's interesting you think about muscle
tears when you're hitting the weights
that kind of does make sense
now it's all about planks lunges and
squats followed by
more pliability exercises such as doing
crunches with a vibrant
vibrating roller beneath his back
caffeine is off the table
so is white flour dairy products and
anything with gluten he steers clear of
veggies
no tomatoes no eggplants no peppers no
mushrooms that could cause
inflammation everything has to be
organic brady each day
tries to drink a couple hundred ounces
of water
usually enhanced with electrolytes he
sells those along with various
nutritional supplements
through the tb12 site that's a shout out
alan campbell was
brady's personal chef from 2013 to 2016
and helped them create the tb12
nutrition manual published in 2017 he
told the post that at the time
at this time of year we focused on dark
leafy greens
some grass-fed animal protein as well as
uh
how do you pronounce that word uh uh of
l-e-g-u-m-e-s legumes legumes and
whole grains but that's not what brady
will eat before the super bowl his game
day meals
are even more basic a smoothie and a
sandwich
of almond butter and jelly it's a
all a far cry from his rookie season in
2000 brady admitted
that his pregame snack used to be nachos
while his
default lunch was ham and cheese subs
with onion rings and a large orange soda
what a weird diet like just very
different
no am i the only one that thinks this is
a very
interesting weird nothing crazy but you
know doesn't touch
mushrooms tomatoes what do you think
about his diet
i mean look he's regimented
he's on point he's got a game plan he's
got a system he's not just winging it
he's not just getting getting nachos
and orange soda he's got a very strict
you know regimen that he's abiding to
the most interesting thing about brady
is
you know there's two tales to brady you
know brady brady came out the
the gates you know he wasn't a a big
time
thrower passer he was a game manager
great defense
they won three championships in his
first four seasons 2002 2004 2005.
do you know that he went on a you know
in 2007
2008 he was the mvp got injured he
missed the season
what's my point here he went 10 years
10 years without winning another super
bowl he won it in 2005 the next super
bowl he won
was in 2015 and then he won in 2015
2017. some say because they got cops
some say because they got cotton they
could no longer film you know the whole
thing with
that's what people say i'm just telling
you yeah you know track record here we
got
10 super bowls in 20 seasons i you know
i i don't think there's much cheating
going on
but call back to you but those are the
guys that are anti-brady you hear that
you hear that 10-year stretch constantly
being saying that
because they could no longer see the
video of the other players how did they
play those ten years so what now still
one they made a playoffs
they lost to the giants they lost the
eagles they lost the eli twice
he reinvented himself he came back
stronger he came back different
sometimes he
when he was younger he was a game
manager then he started leading the
league in passes leading league
touchdowns randy moss is scoring you
know 20 touchdowns a year
reinvented himself now he's managing the
game i mean
he was the mvp of the super bowl he had
200 yards three touchdowns nothing crazy
should have been he's got a system
should have been a coin you love that
guy it's not i love the guy the guy led
the team with 12 tackles eight solo one
interception at the end the guy
psychologically ruined the guys you know
what's his name mahomes ran for 497
yards to runaway rush
record 497 yards he ran in the game not
ran like rushing not rushing running
around running
the defense should have won no
touchdowns nine points less than ten
points go ahead i just
i mean you know i know we're we're
closing up shop here but
man you gotta respect brady's
professionalism
to the game he's got a system he's got a
regimen
and for uh for the 40-plus crowd out
there take notice
he's not drinking uh he's not drinking a
lot of caffeine
he's not working out with major weights
he's stretching
calisthenics right i mean i every
morning you know i do my stretches i do
my yoga or whatever
uh being flexible planks what have you
it's not about getting the pulse dryner
workout in necessarily
shout out to the uh the man paul's
trainer but you know as you get older
your game needs to change a little bit
your regimen needs to change the way
that you work out needs to change
when you're a young buck like kai you
can you know eat you know
seven sandwiches in a day i was out of
my mind by the way
how much bread you admire but you know
things have changed but 43 years old and
you're
you're showing a 25 year old mvp
half a billion dollar contract who the
real man is the goat tom brady
what's up salute kai do you have any
thoughts i mean i think it's
interesting he it he seems like he has
it down to science and i'm sure
the guy he's worked with pretty much his
whole career i mean at that point they
the joke in the article was uh that his
trainer knew tom brady's body more than
his wife
i don't know about that but it makes
sense i don't know about that but
and here's a lesson here to all you
underdogs out there who are just
starting a business that people are
counting you out
you're the you know you're the you're
the 12th man on a on a 12-man team
never forget mario can you pull up his
resume real quick before we
never forget this was his resume
he was the 199th pick yeah in the 2000
draft he was drafted in the sixth round
there's pictures of him with his dad bod
and no abs and no muscle
this is the greatest profession get out
of here found my old
resume really thought i was going to
need this after the fifth round
wow university of michigan bachelor of
general studies december
emphasis in business and psychology 3.4
3.3
that's solid academic achievement honors
90's okay uh uh award the academic
objects
merrill lynch intern ann harbor michigan
assistant to senior sales broker amazing
university of michigan golf course sales
representative assistant clubhouse
manager
1998 polo fields golf and country club
sales representative
uh diddler the dudler and sons custom
home building
they just he's putting them out there so
somebody over there's like wait a minute
doddler this is great
uh uh if imagine your dudler like butler
and sons custom you're going to put that
out there you know
tom brady used to work for us back in
1997 top of the park
in ann arbor summer festival park
security
tom brady was in security
from a security guard to a seven-time
super bowl champion
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye
you